ambition immorality greed deviousness
misery venality remorse nobility
generosity decency and good
old-fashioned cojones
I know these sound like the description
of the requirements to be a successful
successful studio head but in fact these
are the facets of the rainbow of human
behavior reflected by the powerful
performances of our leading Actor
nominees and the Oscar goes to Daniel
day-lewis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the second Academy Award and fourth
nomination for Daniel dinner
but that's the closest I'll ever come to
getting a knighthood so thank you my
deepest thanks to the members of the
Academy for for whacking me with the
handsomest bludgeon in town I'm looking
at this gorgeous thing that you've given
me and thinking back to the first
devilish whisper of an idea that came to
him and everything since and it seems to
me that this sprang like a golden
sapling out of the mad-beautiful head of
Paul Thomas Anderson
I wish my son and my partner HW
Plainview were up here with me the
mighty Dylan Frazier so many people to
thank one amongst them would be mrs.
Plainview down there
the enchantingly optimistic open-minded
and beautiful Rebecca Miller
[Music]
I hope that all those to whom I owe and
whom I feel the deepest gratitude will
forgive me if I say just simply thank
you Paul
I've been thinking a lot about fathers
and sons in the course of this and like
to accept this in the memory of my
grandfather Michael Balkan my father
Cecil day-lewis
and my three fine boys Gabriel Ronan and
Cassius thank you very much indeed thank
you